- Did you have fun at "The Voice?"
- I had a great time at "The Voice."
Did you enjoy?
- I did, but I've been
like a mentor there before,
and you're there so much longer,
because you had to do all the teams.
- You, don't remind me.
It was definitely.
- It's a long time.
Yeah, it's good though.
So we just saw each other there though.
And I heard, and I didn't
know this the day of,
but I just found this out.
Did you have your own trailer?
- I did (laughs)
- I'm, I was like, I love it.
Was it for COVID?
- And you know what?
I figured, you know, with COVID rules,
it'd be better to just
kinda bring your own,
you know what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] I like that.
- Normally you'd be like,
bring your own lunch.
I like brought my own--
- [Kelly] It is like,
- Idea of a trailer.
- [Kelly] So cousin Eddie from,
it fits so cousin Eddie,
I'm so down with it.
(laughter)
So do you bring your trailer everywhere?
Or is it just we were special?
- As of a recent, yeah.
I mean, I think I made
it a home away from home
everywhere I go.
I've been able to kinda drive that thing
up North in California and
go to Yosemite Park, and,
you know, just enjoy this moment,
make the most of these moments.
- Yeah, a lot of people have
seen a bit more national parks
than they generally would take time for,
because of that kinda stuff
and they're beautiful.
- It was super comfortable
though, by the way.
- [Kelly] Yeah, it is?
- Yeah, it's hot in there,
but it's definitely--
- [Kelly] It's hot (laughs)
I'm out.